when I'm back in the white house I will
establish a special presidential
commission really of independent Minds
who are not bought and paid for by big
Pharma and I will charge them with
investigating what is causing the
decades-long increase in chronic
illnesses I understand big Pharma I
believe better than anybody else right I
know where they're coming from
and then I will ask them to publish
recommendations for how every American
child can have a safe and healthy
childhood there you go so it's going to
be another new idea of what we need to
do on health care now you might remember
that when Trump was running in 2015 and
2016 he famously said he was going to
have a beautiful health care plan to
replace Obamacare the only thing that
Republicans proposed in 2017 would have
led to 24 to 32 million people losing
health care so that didn't go anywhere